that guy who sent 2,000 bottle caps to
bethesda is gonna feel really stupid now
that the infinite caps glitch has been
discovered hopefully he didn't cause
himself kidney failure with all that
drinking or he's going to feel even
worse I'm Kate and this is your gamespot
news update a fallout 4 exploit that
gives you basically unlimited bottle
caps the in-game currency has been
discovered if you're scrapping for caps
are need a quick solution you may want
to consider trying this first you'll
need to visit a vendor and choose the
ammo type you want to employ for this
exploit but it must be one you don't
have any of already in your own
inventory then buy it all but don't
complete the sale instead go back to
your inventory and sell back one piece
of the ammo you just bought then still
in your inventory select the same hour
and sell it all back if you've done it
correctly you should be left with one
ammo that you can continually sell back
even though it doesn't really exist note
that this exploit may not work at all
fallout for vendors and the vendors that
do work will have limited caps to give
you but try it add enough places and
someone will probably come through a
variety of video tutorials are also
available on YouTube if you're
interested you may want to act quickly
as the system may fix this through a
future patch do you think exploits like
this are fast have you found any of your
own in fallout 4 let us know in the
comments or find me on Twitter at a
handle to draw I'm cake and thanks for
watching
you